I'll tell you a story from the United
States Marine Corps um I had an
opportunity to visit OCS in quanico
Virginia and the colonel in charge of
OCS um was supposed to give me a
briefing on what they do at OCS and how
they train their officers Etc and he
showed up late and I and I know you know
this but Marines don't show up late ever
um um and he walked into the room and
apologized and said I'm sorry we've had
an incident on bass so of course I was
curious I said what happened what
happened
you know he saidwell it's serious enough
that you know we're considering throwing
one of our Marines out of OCS throwing
one of our Marines out of the Marine
Corps so I'm thinking oh my God what
what crime did this person commit I said
what' he do he said he fell asleep on
Watch and I said that's it like he fell
asleep on watch in the woods of Virginia
and you're going to throw him out of the
Marine Corps for that that's a bit harsh
don't you think and he said no you don't
understand when we asked him about it he
denied it when we asked him about it
again he denied it again and only when
we showed him irrefutable proof did he
say quote I want to take responsibility
for my actions he said the problem we
have is you don't take responsibility
for your actions at the time you get
caught you take responsibility for your
actions at the time you perform your
actions he said we have another Marine
that fell asleep he admitted it we we
punished him but we have no problem with
him and then the colonel went on to
explain he says you have to understand
if I put this kid in a leadership
position in a combat situation and his
Marines think for one minute that he's
trying to protect himself at the expense
of others if he's trying to just Advance
his own career trust will decline trust
will break and people will
die and so I started to understand that
what it means to lead what camaraderie
means in these environments is that is
literally Our Lives depend on each other
and I don't have to like you but I do
have to trust you and I think that in in
the in the civilian world we confuse
those two that I only trust you when I
like you and if I don't like you I don't
trust you